[Music]
[Music]
bullets cannot be recalled they cannot
be uninvented
but they can be taken out of the gun
war is what happens when language fails
[Music]
only the dead have seen the end of war
the truth soldier fights not because he
hates what is in front of him
but because he loves what is behind him
[Music]
never think that war no matter how
necessary
nor how justified is not a crime
[Music]
war does not determine who is right
only who is left
[Music]
all war is a symptom of man's failure as
a thinking animal
[Music]
it is forbidden to kill therefore all
murderers are punished unless they kill
in large numbers and to the sound of
trumpets
there is no flag large enough to cover
the shame of killing innocent people
when the rich wage war
is the poor who die
old men declare war but it is the youth
who must fight and die
how is it possible to have a civil war
how can you have a war on terrorism when
war itself is terrorism
[Music]
the world is full enough of hurts and
missed chances without wars to multiply
them
[Music]
if we don't end war war will end us
religion isn't the cause of wars it's
the excuse
it doesn't matter who wins the war to
someone who's dead
[Music]
i dream of giving birth to a child who
will ask mama what was war
[Music]
it is well that war is so terrible
or we should grow too fond of it
[Music]
they won the war but lost the peace
once you hear the details of victory it
is hard to distinguish it from defeat
[Music]
the military doesn't start wars
politicians do
[Music]
you don't spread democracy through the
barrel of a gun
[Music]
politics is war and in war truth is the
first casualty
[Music]
war grows out of the desire of the
individual to gain advantage at the
expense of his fellow man
[Music]
the folly of war is that it can have no
natural end except the extinction of an
entire race of people
you must learn to end the wars in your
world by ending them in your mind
who are proud of their guns
tanks and missiles are deprived of
humanity
[Music]
we will not learn how to live together
in peace by killing each other's
children
nothing will end war unless the people
themselves refuse to go to war
how vile and despicable war seems to me
i would rather be hacked to pieces than
take part in such an abominable business
you don't liberate a country standing on
the soil of another
there never was a good war or a bad
peace
[Music]
there is nothing so likely to produce
peace as to be well prepared to meet the
enemy
peace is not achieved by controlling
nations
but by mastering our thoughts
never for the sake of peace and quiet
deny your own experience or convictions
peace is the virtue of civilization
war is its crime
pieces constructed not fought for
there is a higher court than the courts
of justice
and that is the court of conscience it
supersedes all other courts
no protracted war can fail to endanger
the freedom of a democratic country
the executive has no right to determine
if there is or is not cause for
declaring war
we seek peace knowing that peace is the
climate of freedom
peace cannot be kept by force
it can only be achieved by understanding
true peace is not merely the absence of
tension
it is the presence of justice
you